this video is voted for by patrons of
questions for science
unless you're living under a rock you
must have heard about the recent
breakthrough in cold fusion technology
I'm talking about probably one of the
greatest achievements in human history
this breakthrough will solve all our
energy problems and be able to provide
power to every person in the world if
you're curious about this breakthrough
that you haven't heard of I'm talking
about this 1989 paper claiming to
witness induced nuclear fusion of
deuterium sure it's been 30 years and
there is still no replicable evidence
but I'm sure they're just working out
the kinks
we should have legitimate cold fusion
any day now any day now
any day now any
[Music]
any day now
oh and brains before the bunking
coldfusion we first have to understand
what nuclear fusion is fusion is when
two nuclei under the right conditions
fuse together causing an immense release
of energy if you can create fusion you
can use the heat from the reaction to
convert water into steam to the internet
generator which sends electricity to
homes and voila power this all sounds
well and good but it's not going to
happen at least not for a while because
a temperature to permit the conditions
for fusion are insanely high hmm no much
hotter than this the high heat causes to
necessary changes to the atomic nuclei
for fusion to occur firstly the high
temperature energizes the electrons so
much that they're stripped off the
orbitals around the nuclei this changes
the atoms into a naked nuclei and causes
them to freely bounce around in a hot
plasma of other nuclei normally when
these positively charged nuclei come in
within close distance of each other
naturally they would repel but this is
nuclear fusion so where's that even the
temperature has to be so high that the
kinetic energy of the nuclei is stronger
than the electrostatic forces repelling
the two nuclei once these two conditions
are met we can achieve nuclear fusion
but just how hot do the conditions have
to be for this to happen just a little
north of 109 degrees Celsius at the
moment the only place capable of
maintaining this temperature is the
Sun's core now this brings us to the
hundred million dollar question pun
intended if you need 100 million degrees
Celsius to achieve nuclear fusion how is
cold fusion that is fusion at room
temperature possible well here's the
thing it's not well it kind of is but
technically hmm no but yes all right
there is actually two types of cold
fusion the first is called muon
catalyzed fusion and involves using
muons instead of electrons and occurs at
room temperature hence it being cold me
Ones are similar to electrons in that
they're both subatomic particles and are
negatively charged
but muons are much heavier and therefore
orbit closer to the nuclei allowing the
nuclei to get within closer proximity to
each other without repelling this close
proximity allows fusion to occur under
the right conditions the only downside
is muons have very short life spans of
two microseconds and the energy it takes
to produce them is more than the energy
generated by the fusion reaction so at
the moment UN catalyze fusion is kind of
useless the other cold fusion is the one
that's more widely cited by the
pseudoscience crowd and is known as
deuterium induced fusion in the late
1980s two scientist by the name of
Stanley pons and Martin Fleischmann who
worked at the University of Utah
believed they had discovered
room-temperature fusion by fusing
deuterium atoms together to make helium
for isotope here's the explanation of
their cold fusion experiment in the
protocol pons and Fleischmann set up a
solution in lithium salts and heavy
water which is just a water molecule
with deuterium atoms instead of hydrogen
next a palladium and platinum rod were
immersed in the solution and attached to
a battery when a voltage was applied the
deuterium atoms separated from the
oxygen and heavy water molecule into
positively charged deuterium ions these
positive deuterium ions navigated to the
negatively charged plate 'i'm strip upon
reaching the Palladium the ions gain an
electron and are either converted into
diatomic deuterium or a single deuterium
atom the diatomic deuterium floats out
of the solution as a gas while the
deuterium atoms being so small are able
to migrate into the Palladium lattice Y
atomic deuterium is migrating into a
palladium structure is beyond me and
makes no sense but then again so does
cold fusion
so whatever as a voltage is further
increased more deuterium atoms migrate
deeper into the palladium lattice
eventually so many deuterium atoms enter
that it begins to expand and contract
this expansion and contraction causes
the deuterium atoms to move back and
forth in a uniform motion then by some
unknown mechanism the deuterium atoms
decide to fuse together forming a helium
4 isotope giving off excessive amount of
heat which in theory if were to be
scaled up could power blah blah blah you
get the picture ok I got some questions
firstly how do they manage to bring the
atoms close to each other without using
naked nuclei or muons how were the
deuterium atoms able to overcome the
electrostatic forces that repel all
atoms well that didn't matter because
the University of Utah got one of these
results and set up a press conference
ASAP in order to set a precedent to
patent the new technology well in the
world of scientific research jumping to
a press conference after you've obtained
your initial
without doing an exhaustive application
first is sorta especially when that
discovery is held in regard by the
community as being highly impossible
this led to a whirlwind of negative
press from the scientific community who
started calling the discovery cold
fusion as a backhanded remark it got
much worse when other researchers
attempted to replicate the experiment
including Fleischmann and pons as
michael j Schaefer puts it a senior
scientist at a major fusion Research Lab
who is familiar with the story of cold
fusion stated there was an immediate
rush to reproduce the pons and
Fleischmann experiments a few
experimenters reported success many
others failure even those who reported
success had difficulty reproducing their
results furthermore no one was seeing
the expected fusion products that last
line no one was seeing the expected
fusion products was the final nail in
the coffin for cold fusion in theory
fusion of deuterium nuclei would yield a
helium 4 isotope and gamma radiation
though helium 4 was measured in
extremely small quantities its presence
was attributed to the scarce helium
found in the atmosphere but more
importantly the real necessary fusion
product that needed to be present was
gamma radiation if it could be measured
then the arguments illustrated by the
School of Athens painting would be that
the helium present wasn't from the
atmosphere ie Plato's hand but instead
came from the jet fusion according to
Aristotle unfortunately no gamma
radiation was ever detected indicating
fusion never took place
pons and Fleischmann continued to
attempt to reproduce their results but
ultimately failed
[Music]
in 1992 Toyota's seeing a potential in
cold fusion technology hired both
scientists to continue their research in
their Imber lab in southern France life
was good for pons and Fleischmann a
state-of-the-art lab in southern France
with millions of dollars worth of
funding now they could prove the cold
fusion heaters wrong
surely this would show that
room-temperature fusion was possible
three years later Fleischman broke off
and began his own research in England in
1998 Toyota terminated their contract
with pons after spending nearly 40
million dollars on cold fusion research
and arriving with no tangible evidence
that same year the company stopped all
investigative research into cold fusion
technology now cold fusion a distant bad
memory for the science community
occasionally lurks on conspiracy forms
and pseudoscience groups on the Internet
some believe cold fusion was sabotage by
oil corporations or the US government
some have claimed there are scientists
who've achieved it but aren't getting
funding or fair coverage to further
their research alas we may never know
wait no cold fusion is both on the
stupid scale I'm reading cold fusion at
a 5 out of 10 because understanding
nuclear fusion doesn't come easy to most
people for the harmful skill it's at a 1
out of 10 because cold fusion doesn't
really harm anyone except maybe
investors pocketbooks so 2 out of 10 and
click the bell to subscribe you know
[Music]